in 2009 I went from my state school in
Bristol to Oxford University where I
studied physics for four years at some
pieces of college in 2010 I realized
that I had a valuable perspective as an
applicant from a state comprehensive
school whose parents didn't go to
university and so I made a youtube
channel from Simon Oxford physics sorry
about the F I know it's annoying and I
started making videos at first these
were answering questions that I've got
about Oxford all the time and then
eventually in my fourth year I've logged
every week about Oxford student life
then when I moved to Exeter from Oxford
for my PhD I kept vlogging about my PhD
progress but also branched out and made
videos on studying on music and vlogger
tags so what now there are three kinds
of videos that can be coming out on this
channel in the future one vlogging and
personal videos so that's going to
include my xbox where I talk about my
PhD progress but also other topics like
my favorite books to science and
environmental content and in particular
more videos on interesting topics in
physics some related to my research
Matmos ferric physics but some not in
the near future that's going to include
videos on this trip I on faster than
light travel and how to live sustainably
as a student and lastly three
educational content so that's going to
include longer form videos like my crash
course in atmospheric physics but also
other topics like the nature of teaching
and applying for PhDs so why those kinds
of videos I think that people subscribe
to youtube channels for two reasons the
content that's covered and the way in
which that content is presented now the
videos the content that I want to make
is scientific in nature or educational
in nature I love talking about the way
that the world works and trying to
communicate that to people to educate
them and I'm passionate about education
and making sure everyone has access to
it in a fair way but if I'm going to
make those videos I want to make them my
way I'm not just going to make generic
videos otherwise you could subscribe to
any number of other fantastic channels
on YouTube I'm not saying that I want to
make content that's better than a green
CGP grey or Brady Haran I want to make
content there's my content that's just
different what I'm trying to say is that
this is going to be a hybrid channel
it's not going to be just a science or
of studying or educational
it's also my personal channel so yeah I
am going to make videos that are
scientific or educational made in the
matter that I want to make them but then
I'm also going to make videos that are
purely personal like vlogs or talking
about books and some people will be here
just for the forum and some people will
be here just for the latter some awesome
people will be here for you know both
and the point is all of that spine at
the end of the day I'm just going to
make the videos that I want to make in
the way that I want to make them and if
people like you want to watch them
that's just a bonus if you like the
sound of science through the filter of
Simon or just the idea of me talking
about things that I find cool then stick
around subscribe to the channel I really
look forward to seeing in the comments
because I hope that this channel can
become a hub for people who are
interested in the world who want to be
educated about it and want to go on to
do great things and maybe are massive
geeks I'm already so lucky to have an
amazing community of people who watch my
videos and comment on them and interact
with each other and I want nothing more
than for that community to grow and to
become more and more interconnected and
that includes you watching this video
right now if you like the sound of all
of this then subscribe to the channel or
stick around if you're ready subscribed
and I better get back to making more
videos